I feel like this is kind of a trend
right now where folks are calling in and
they've said I want that I want to be a
stay-at-home mom and I want to live in
the best school districts and I want
Jimmy to have the best possible and it's
like but if you can't afford it you've
gotta It's gotta make sense it's got to
make sense in in the span of your
reality and sometimes you have the
opportunity to make it make sense if
you're willing to sacrifice but you
can't have it all without willing to
sacrifice that's important I wanted we
wanted to stop this private school
tuition in the case of the example I
just gave and we wanted to get rid of
the IRS after bankruptcy because the IRS
never goes away right we're one of those
people out of our life and we want the
kids in a school system
we also wanted to own a house
but we one of those other things more
than owning a house